former president barack obama is
speaking to cbs news in his first tv
interview since the 2020 election
he's about to release his long-awaited
memoir it's called a promised land
scott pelley interviewed the 44th
president for 60 minutes
and we got to sit down with him for cbs
sunday morning
president obama reflected on the start
of his own administration and how his
experience
was very different from the transition
that president trump is blocking
right now when donald trump won
i stayed up until 2 30 in the morning
and
i then called donald trump to
congratulate him
his margin of victory over hillary
clinton wasn't
greater than joe biden's martin over him
yeah but if you are listening to some of
the talk radio
that trump voters are listening to if
you're watching fox news if you're
getting these tweets
those allegations are presented as facts
so you've got millions of people out
there who think oh yeah there must be
cheating because the president said so
i think about john mccain calling george
and laura bush welcoming you and
michelle obama to the white house could
not have been more gracious i remember
you
inviting donald trump to the white house
i'll never forget it because you said
i wish that you succeed because we want
the country to succeed
what is at stake here well look joe
biden will be the next president of the
united states kamala harris will be the
next vice president there is no
legal basis he's getting support from
members of the republican party who are
not challenging him
and that has been disappointing they
obviously didn't think there was any
fraud going on
because they didn't say anything about
it for the first two days but there's
damage to this
because what happens is that the
peaceful
transfer of power the notion that
any of us who attain an elected office
whether it's dog catcher or president
are servants of the people
it's a temporary job we're not above the
rules we're not above the law
that's the essence of our democracy
and you can see more of our conversation
this sunday on cbs sunday morning and
scott pelley's interview with former
president obama sunday night on 60
minutes so i think cbs got a one-two
punch we were very grateful for that
we were at the natural uh the national
portrait gallery right which is a very
interesting setting because you have the
portrait of president obama and the
portrait of michelle obama
and the book as i've mentioned a couple
of times anthony's over 700
pages so there's a lot of information
is it every day so there's a lot of
information but you know he talks about
the start of his presidency
the bumps along the way regrets he's had
rediscovering life love life and love
with michelle
again it's a great setting because that
gallery is about legacy
yes that's right yes there is a little
plaque next to every picture
and it is a legacy plaque we all felt
very proud to be there thank you
president obama